30 jours 30 jours que Gaza est bombardé
jour et nuit 30 jours de siège sans aide
humanitaire sans eau sans vivre sans
refuge 30 jours qui transforment cette
prison en cimetière à ciel ouvert avec
des milliers de morts civiles dont des
milliers d'enfants 30 jours où le droit
légitime à se défendre s'est transformé
en vengeance aveugle et illégale 30
jours d'angoisse pour les otages et
leurs familles 30 jours de violation du
droit international 30 jours où
souscouvert de combattre le terrorisme
on le nourrit et le renforce Dominique
de Villepin le rappelait encore hier ni
la force ni la vengeance n'ass sur la
paix et la sécurité seule la justice
peut le faire 30 jours que nous
attendons une parole forte et claire de
la France pour in cesser le feu le
retour de l'aide humanitaire et la
libération des otages le soutien
inconditionnel de la France aux
opérations militaires d'Israël et à
l'occupation est une erreur tragique qui
marquera l'histoire de façon dramatique
cela ne sert ni les Israéliens ni les
Palestiniens depuis 10 ans la France a
vendu 209 millions d'euros d'armes vers
Israël bomb requette missile utilisé
contre la population de Gaza la France a
pourtant ratifié le traité sur le
commerce des armes de l'ONU dont
l'article 6 prévoit l'arrêt des
exportations si ces armes sont employées
pour commettre un génocide des crimes
contre l'humanité des état des attaques
dirigées contre des civils ou des crimes
de guerre nous ne pouvons pas attendre
un jour de plus madame la Premier
ministre à la veille de la conférence
humanitaire la France a une occasion de
faire entendre une voix forte singulière
et courageuse comptez-vous adopter un
embargo sur les ventes d'armes comme
l'avait fait le général de Gaulle lors
de la guerre des 6 jours comptez-vous
reconnaître l'état palestinien comme l'a
voté le Parlement en 2014 comptez-vous
appeler à l'arrêt et au retrait des
colonisations pour préserver la solution
à deux états madame la Première ministre
face à cette folie meurtrière nous avons
besoin de réponsse précises merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Guillaume
Gontard depuis les terribles attaques
terroristes perpétrées par le Hamas
contre Israël la situation dans la
région est extrêmement
préoccupante Israël a le droit d'assurer
la sécurité de son territoire mais cela
doit se faire dans le respect du droit
international et nous devons
impérativement éviter l'escalade et
l'embrasement dans la région et je le
dis sans ambigué la situation
humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza est
dramatique le bilan humain est
extrêmement lourd avec de nombreuses
victimes civiles notamment des femmes et
des enfants les populations
palestiniennes ne doivent pas payer pour
les crimes du Hamas elles doivent être
protégées de toute
urgence cette urgence la France n'a
cessé de la réaffirmer et nous avons
condamné très clairement les frappes
contre les personnels humanitaires et
les sites de l'ONU comme nous l'avons
dit le droit international humanitaire
impose des principes clairs de
distinction de nécessité de
proportionnalité et de précaution la
protection des civils est à la fois un
impératif moral et une obligation
internationale une trêve humanitaire
immédiate et durable est absolument
nécessaire elle doit pouvoir mener à un
cesser le feu
monsieur le Président Gontard la France
est mobilisée pour la paix à
l'initiative du Président de la
République une conférence humanitaire
internationale pour la population civile
de Gaza se tiendra demain à Paris
j'ajoute que nous suivons de très près
la situation de nos ressortissants dans
la bande de Gaza nous nous mettons tout
en œuvre pour leur permettre de revenir
en France plus de 100 ont pu quitter
Gaza depuis vendredi dernier de plus
nous restons mobilisés pour obtenir une
libération immédiate et sans condition
des otages monsieur le Président Gontard
face à ce conflit la seule issue
possible est une solution politique avec
deux états c'est la position invariable
de la France c'est le sens de
l'initiative pour la paix et la sécurité
pour tous porté par le Président de la
République autour de trois piliers la
sécurité avec une lutte implacable
contre le terrorisme le soutien
humanitaire avec une réponse
internationale rapide et forte face à
l'urgence de Gaza et la détermination à
relancer un processus politique
permettant de garantir la sécurité
d'Israël et la création d'un État pour
les populations palestiniennes face à la
situation au Proche Orient la France ne
ménage aucun effort pour éviter
l'embrasement pour protéger les civils
et pour offrir une perspective de Pai je
vous
remercie merci Madame
la